.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Moskau.
Es ist der 24. Februar 2022.
Seit heute Morgen rollt
der Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine -
und wir haben vor drei Wochen
mit einer Reportage
über drei russische Frauen begonnen.
Von meinen Bekannten in der Ukraine
ist bis jetzt niemand
verletzt oder getötet worden.
Aber es macht mir Angst.
Einige verstecken sich.
Über drei mutige Frauen.
Zeitlebens
kämpfe ich gegen diesen Dreck.
Muss ich nun darin sterben?
Drei Frauen, die in Russland
für Gleichberechtigung,
für Meinungsfreiheit
und Rechtsstaatlichkeit kämpfen.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Ich habe das starke Gefühl,
dass jetzt das Recht
Russland verlassen hat.
Zehn Jahre lang
war ich Russland-Korrespondent.
Ich habe in dieser Zeit miterlebt,
wie die Bürgerrechte in diesem Land
mehr und mehr beschnitten wurden.
Ich frage mich an diesem kalten,
grauen Februarmorgen:
Was geschieht jetzt
mit Ksenia, Zalina und Mari?
Wie wird der Krieg
ihr Leben verändern?
Drei Wochen zuvor:
Drehbeginn in Rostow am Don,
im wirtschaftlichen
und kulturellen Zentrum Südrusslands.
Hier lebt eine der drei Frauen,
die wir ein halbes Jahr lang
begleiten wollen:
Ksenia Usolkina.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Ksenia fährt heute Abend
in eine Nachbarstadt,
nach Taganrog.
Sie wird dort
mit ihrer Geschäftspartnerin Julia
einen neuen Lehrgang
ihrer Modelschule starten.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Einer nicht ganz gewöhnlichen
Modelschule.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Die alleinerziehende Mutter
hatte zwölf Jahre lang
in der Verwaltung bei der Bahn
gearbeitet.
Da organisierte ihr Arbeitgeber
einen Schönheitswettbewerb
und Arbeitskolleginnen fanden,
sie solle doch mitmachen.
Natürlich waren alle dagegen.
Mein damaliger Mann fand:
"Du hast dort nichts verloren."
Und meine Mutter:
"Du hast Familie,
du hast doch keine Zeit für so was."
Und zack habe ich gewonnen.
Weitere Siege kamen hinzu
und Ksenia begann,
professionell zu modeln.
Daraus entstand die Idee
einer Modelschule.
* Russische Popmusik *
You're welcome.
Ksenia richtet sich mit ihren Kursen
an Frauen jeden Alters
und ohne Standardmasse.
Ihr Credo lautet: Die Welt
braucht neue Schönheitsideale.
Ich will, dass wir alle
diese Sicherheit kriegen,
dass wir wunderschön sind.
Wir sollten uns nicht
mit anderen vergleichen -
eine ist schlank
und ich bin nicht so schlank.
Aber auch ich
habe mein gewisses Etwas.
* Russische Popmusik *
Ich habe ein kleines Problem
mit meinen Gefühlen.
Ich lächle immer alle an.
Aber ich möchte auch
meine anderen Gefühle zeigen können.
* Sie schreien laut. *
(Ksenia) Lauter!
Noch lauter, komm!
Ach, man möchte dich
am liebsten küssen.
Komm, mach die Haare auf!
Lass die Dämonen raus, los!
Mehr!
Wenn ich mir erlauben kann,
so zu lachen und so zu schreien,
dann kommen meine Dämonen raus.
Und ich mache kein Geheimnis daraus:
Ich liess mich
von meinem ersten Ehemann scheiden,
nachdem er mich
zusammengeschlagen hatte
und ich im Krankenhaus gelandet war.
Das gibt es bei uns leider oft,
aber immer weniger.
Warum?
Früher hatten die Frauen Angst
und haben geschwiegen.
Heute sprechen sie darüber.
Sie drehen sich um und gehen.
Sie dulden das nicht mehr.
Seid ihr
durch die Polizei geschützt?
* Lachen *
Bei uns sagt man: Erst wenn er
dich absticht, kommen sie vorbei.
Das stimmt nicht.
Die Polizei kommt und fragt:
"Alle noch am Leben?"
"Gut, dann tschüss,
das ist Familiensache."
Nowogirejewo - ein Stadtteil
an der Moskauer Peripherie.
Es ist immer noch Anfang Februar.
Immer noch rechnet kaum jemand
in der russischen Bevölkerung
mit einem Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine -
auch nicht die Bloggerin,
die ich heute besuche.
Ich habe mich mit ihr
und ihrer kleinen Familie verabredet.
Auf ihrem Blog "Weibliche Macht"
kommentiert Zalina Marshenkulova
die laufenden Ereignisse in Russland.
Ideenreich, selbstironisch und bissig
hat sie sich bei einer städtischen
und jüngeren Bevölkerung
bekannt gemacht.
Hallo, mit euch
ist die Ungerechtigkeit im Quadrat:
Zalina Marshenkulova.
So bekannt, dass LEGO
eine Figur nach ihr kreiert hat.
Seit 14 Jahren
ist sie mit Jegor verheiratet.
Seit zwei Jahren
sind die beiden Eltern.
Ihr Bub heisst Wanja.
Seid ihr eine gewöhnliche
russische Familie?
Wie sieht denn
eine ungewöhnliche aus?
Ich meine, wenn die Frau Feministin
ist: Hat das einen Einfluss?
Bei uns ist es so,
dass sich mein Mann
wirklich ums Kind kümmert -
und zwar mit ganzer Seele.
Ein Mann, der so was tut,
ist in Russland leider immer noch
eine Ausnahme, wirklich ein Held.
Und was sagen deine Freunde dazu,
dass deine Frau Feministin ist?
Wir haben gar keine Freunde, oder?
Viele haben Angst
vor dem Wort Feminismus.
Aber wenn man es ihnen erklärt,
dann verstehen sie es.
Wir sind eben
eine gewöhnliche Familie.
Das ist wie beim Wort Demokratie.
Ja, kommt darauf an,
was du damit meinst.
Das Wort ist gut,
so wie Feminismus,
aber viele Leute
bewerten es heute negativ.
Zwei Jahre lang
warteten Zalina und Jegor
auf einen öffentlichen Kita-Platz.
Jetzt haben sie Wanja
bei einer privaten Kita angemeldet.
Es sind 40 Min. Weg dahin.
Und wir stehen immer noch
auf Platz 150 in der Warteschlange.
Fürsorge wird nur versprochen.
Sie sagen: "Gebär! Gebär!"
Aber dann gibt es keinen Kita-Platz
und wir müssen selber
dafür bezahlen.
Wir haben viele
solcher Widersprüche.
Das ist es ja,
die Regierung sagt immer wieder:
"Kinder, Mütter -
das ist unser Heiligtum."
Aber eigentlich
spucken sie auf das Volk.
In Russland wird ja jetzt viel
von Familienwerten gesprochen.
Eben, die Leute sprechen nur
darüber, aber sie leben es nicht.
Wenn jemand von Familienwerten
spricht, dann heisst es,
dass er ein Problem damit hat.
Unser wichtigster Wert:
keine Gewalt.
In Russland -
in anderen Ländern ja auch -
ist häusliche Gewalt
wirklich ein Riesenproblem.
Und was bei uns als
"traditioneller Wert" verkauft wird,
ist eigentlich
die Versklavung der Frau.
Sie muss alles erdulden,
und er kann saufen, sie schlagen -
er kann machen, was er will.
Das sind die sog.
traditionellen Werte bei uns.
Und wir leben das Gegenteil:
Respekt, Liebe, keine Gewalt.
Wir brauchen nie Gewalt,
weder untereinander
noch mit dem Kind.
Wir behandeln den anderen so
wie uns selbst.
Wir behandeln alle Menschen so.
- Ja, das sind unsere Werte.
Und was die Männer in Russland
betrifft:
Die meisten sind es nicht gewohnt,
nachzugeben.
Sie vermeiden darum Beziehungen
mit starken Frauen,
oder gehen daran kaputt,
sie überarbeiten sich oder saufen.
Was für ein Mann soll Wanja werden?
Kein richtiger.
Tschüss, Häschen.
Darf ich?
- Ja.
(Schweizerdeutsch) Die Tür öffnen
darf man dann trotzdem.
Wir fahren ins Moskauer Zentrum.
Wie war denn deine Kindheit?
Strenge Eltern?
Es war eher desolat.
Sie haben alle gesoffen,
haben einander verprügelt.
Es gab Messerstechereien
und Ähnliches.
Untersuchungen zeigen,
dass jede dritte Frau in Russland
von häuslicher Gewalt betroffen ist.
In Zalinas Blog
erscheinen immer wieder
Fotos und Videos von Übergriffen.
Er hat mich so zugerichtet.
Kurz vor unserem Besuch
rief Zalina ihre Community auf,
ein Foto von sich zu posten,
um zu zeigen,
dass da auch eine andere,
gewaltfreie Gesellschaft ist.
Ihren Lebensunterhalt verdient sie in
einer Werbeagentur als PR-Beraterin.
Ihr Herzensprojekt aber ist ihr Blog,
mit dem sie Gleichgesinnte vernetzen
und ihnen Mut machen kann.
Ein Beispiel: Eine Frau
war unglücklich verheiratet
und die ganze Verwandtschaft
sagte ihr:
"Lass dich nicht scheiden!"
"Familie ist das Wichtigste."
"Sei geduldig,
er ist doch so ein guter Ehemann."
"Egal, ob du ihn liebst oder nicht,
lass dich nicht scheiden."
Und meine Texte halfen ihr,
aufzustehen, sich scheiden zu lassen
und endlich das zu machen,
was sie sich eigentlich wünschte.
Ich habe viele solche Geschichten.
Die Publikation
mit dem bisher grössten Echo
war ihre Werbekampagne für Reebok.
Zalina trat darin auch selber auf.
Ihr Text:
"Hör auf, ständig auf die Anerkennung
von einem Mann zu warten,
setz dich lieber
einem Mann aufs Gesicht!"
Junge Männer schreiben jetzt
auf den Dating-Seiten:
"Wir können ins Café oder du kannst
mir auch aufs Gesicht sitzen."
Gespräche über Cunnilingus
und Facesitting
waren plötzlich nicht mehr tabu.
Das ist kulturelle Beeinflussung.
Zuerst verändern wir die Kultur
und danach kommen
die strukturellen Veränderungen.
Es wird den Menschen zu eng
in den Strukturen und sie beginnen,
die tektonischen Platten
zu schieben.
In dieser Strasse
führt eine Anwältin ihre Kanzlei.
Auch sie besuchen wir drei Wochen
vor Beginn des Angriffskrieges
zum ersten Mal.
Mari Davtyan.
Immer wieder
hat sie spektakuläre Mandate,
z.B. die drei Schwestern
Khachaturyan.
Sie töteten im Affekt ihren Vater,
nachdem er sie über Jahre
gequält und missbraucht hatte.
Sie sind mittlerweile
auf freiem Fuss.
Als sie des Mordes angeklagt wurden,
gab es im ganzen Land
Solidaritätskundgebungen.
Denn kurz zuvor
hatte das russische Parlament
häusliche Gewalt bagatellisiert,
den Schutz der Frauen
stark reduziert.
Wäre ich gläubig, würde ich sagen:
"Die Parlamentarier
werden dafür büssen."
Seither haben wir
noch mehr Gewaltfälle.
Schlägt er dich, liebt er dich.
Ja. Wenn der Mann seine Frau
verprügelt, heisst es, er liebe sie.
Wir haben viele Sprichwörter,
die Gewalt rechtfertigen.
Und diese Idee
"Wer stärker ist, der hat recht"
hören wir in letzter Zeit
sehr oft in unserem Land.
Das ist Systemverhalten,
um Macht und Kontrolle auszuüben -
in der Familie und
auf allen Ebenen der Gesellschaft.
Mari Davtyan war Klägerin
im Namen eines Opfers
extremer häuslicher Gewalt:
Margarita Gracheva.
Ihr Ehemann hackte ihr die Hände ab.
Ihre linke Hand
konnte wieder angenäht werden,
rechts trägt sie heute eine Prothese.
Wäre früher gehandelt worden,
hätte Rita heute noch beide Hände.
Bei ihrer ersten Anzeige hätte man
sie vor ihrem Mann schützen können.
Auch für schwere Übergriffe,
auch im Wiederholungsfall,
gibt es heute höchstens eine Busse.
Es können keine Strafverfahren
eingeleitet werden,
bis es zu spät ist.
Darum: Nehmen Sie das Gesetz
gegen häusliche Gewalt an!
Retten Sie Leben!
Mit diesem und ähnlichen Fällen
wandte sich Mari Davtyan
an den Europäischen Gerichtshof
für Menschenrechte.
Im Dezember 2021
der Entscheid aus Strassburg:
Russland wird aufgefordert,
seine Gesetze zu ändern.
Russland kann sich nicht verweigern.
Aber bisher äusserte sich erst
Putins Pressesprecher Peskow dazu.
Er sagte: "Ich habe das Urteil nicht
gelesen, aber ich erhebe Einspruch."
Genau so hat er es formuliert.
Aber ich meine, du schlägst doch
in der Familie einfach nicht.
Ja, aber dafür braucht es
eine entsprechende Erziehung
und entsprechende Ideale.
Die Menschen
müssten gewaltlos erzogen werden.
Was aber nicht der Fall ist.
- Was nicht der Fall ist.
Noch schlimmer:
Wir sehen in den letzten Jahren
eine starke Militarisierung
der Gesellschaft.
Mich beunruhigt stark,
was bereits in den Schulen abläuft.
Die Kinderarmee -
ich kriege Gänsehaut,
wenn ich achtjährige Kinder
in Uniform sehe,
wie sie zu Militärmusik marschieren.
Wir verstehen doch, dass diese
Erziehung zur Gewaltbereitschaft
uns früher oder später
zum Verhängnis wird.
Dass diese Gewaltbereitschaft
schon bald zu einem Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine führt,
will auch ich
noch kurz zuvor nicht glauben.
Obwohl die Alarmzeichen
auf Rot stehen
und Putin grosse Truppenverbände -
offiziell zu Übungszwecken -
an der Grenze zur Ukraine
zusammenzieht.
Ich bin wieder
in der südrussischen Stadt Rostow,
weil ich sehen will,
was sich in Ksenias Modelkurs tut.
In einer ehemaligen Uhrenfabrik
hat Ksenia einen Raum
für ein Fotoshooting hergerichtet.
* Verführerischer Song:
"Stop" von Sam Brown *
# Now I find you've lied
# and I can't believe it's true.
Die Gesellschaft hat uns bei-
gebracht, dass eine Frau bescheiden
und anständig sein soll,
ja nicht vulgär.
Und eine junge Frau
soll keusch sein.
Und heute werden wir -
natürlich ohne Ihre Kamera -
das böse Mädchen
aus ihnen herausholen.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Ich arbeite
in einer geschlossenen Anstalt.
Ein Schritt zu viel nach links
oder rechts
und du wirst erschossen.
Nein, das war jetzt ein Witz.
Aber wenn du in einer
geschlossenen Anstalt arbeitest,
wünschst du dir schon ab und zu mal
eine Abwechslung.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es gibt mir Selbstvertrauen.
Als Person, als Frau.
Ich kann mich als Frau entfalten
und eine innere Beklemmung lösen.
In mir sind unglaubliche Gefühle
hochgekommen,
die ich gar nicht kannte.
Wir haben ausprobiert:
In welchem Zustand
fühlst du dich wohler?
Wie ist es, Opfer zu sein?
Und wie ist es,
wenn du als Frau die Macht hast?
Wir treffen Ksenias Sohn.
Er und seine Mutter
wollen zusammen auf den Markt.
Ilja hat gerade
seinen Grundwehrdienst beendet,
hat mit seiner Freundin eine Wohnung
genommen und sucht jetzt Arbeit -
und für heute
einen neuen Trainingsanzug.
Ksenia hat ihn allein grossgezogen.
Es war manchmal schon hart für mich.
Mama war
alles gleichzeitig für mich:
Mama und Papa, Oma und Opa.
Aber ich bin glücklich,
so wie es ist.
Sie finden also, eine Frau
sollte eigentlich nicht arbeiten?
Ja, der Mann soll das Geld verdienen
und die Frau den Haushalt machen.
Der Mann führt,
die Frau geht Hand in Hand mit ihm.
Anders geht es nicht.
Welche Eigenschaften
sind für Sie bei einer Frau wichtig?
Sie soll fürsorglich sein, liebend.
So kann sie aufblühen -
in den Händen des Mannes.
Und treu.
- Ich bin so stolz auf dich, Sohn.
Fürsorglich - wie meinen Sie das?
- Mit meiner Freundin ist es so:
Nach der Arbeit erwartet mich schon
das Essen auf dem Tisch.
Die Sachen für morgen
sind vorbereitet.
Sie kümmert sich darum,
was ich esse,
wie ich aussehe,
wie ich mich fühle.
Zwei Wochen später schickt Wladimir
Putin Militär in die Ukraine,
um das Land unter seine
politische Kontrolle zu bringen.
In den ersten Tagen
des Angriffskrieges
gehen in russischen Städten Zehn-
tausende aus Protest auf die Strasse.
Die Polizei
greift überall hart durch.
Ksenia ist in Moskau -
wegen geschäftlicher Termine.
Ich treffe sie
auf ihrem Weg zum Flughafen.
Sie ist aufgewühlt.
Ich will nicht darüber nachdenken
und konzentriere mich jetzt einfach
auf meine Arbeit.
Politik ist nicht meine Stärke,
darum will ich das Thema
gar nicht kommentieren.
Ich schaue ab und zu auf Instagram,
sonst sehe ich mir nichts an.
Da werde ich nur panisch.
Und ich kann eh nichts ändern.
Und demonstrieren -
dagegen oder dafür?
Dazu bin ich nicht bereit -
weder dafür noch dagegen.
Ich verstehe im Moment
sowieso nicht, was los ist.
Sagen wir so:
Niemand braucht einen Krieg.
Alle wollen Frieden
und das Leben leben,
das wir vorher gelebt haben.
Vor solch
einer schweren Entscheidung
sind wir noch nie gestanden.
Wir werden für eine bestimmte Zeit
den Sendebetrieb einstellen.
Nein zum Krieg!
- Nein zum Krieg!
Lichterlöschen
bei den letzten kritischen Medien,
die noch da waren.
Es gilt ein neues Gesetz
über sog. Falschnachrichten
über das Militär.
Wer statt von einer "militärischen
Sonderaktion" von "Krieg" spricht
und den Krieg kritisiert,
riskiert jahrelange Haftstrafen.
Journalismus ist unter solchen
Bedingungen nicht mehr möglich.
Wenige Blogger und Bloggerinnen
sind im Land selber
noch publizistisch aktiv,
wie z.B. Zalina.
Sie teilt in den ersten Kriegstagen
Videos über Demonstrationen
und Festnahmen.
* Die Leute skandieren Parolen
auf Russisch. *
* Aufschrei *
Sie teilt Links zu Seiten
von ausländischen Medien,
die offiziell gesperrt sind
und postet eine Rede
des ukrainischen Präsidenten.
Die Ukraine in euren Nachrichten
und die Ukraine im echten Leben
sind zwei vollkommen
unterschiedliche Länder.
Der Hauptunterschied besteht darin,
dass unsere Ukraine echt ist.
Und Zalina schreibt:
"Liebe Abonnentinnen und Abonnenten
aus der Ukraine,
ich schäme mich zutiefst dafür,
was im Moment geschieht."
"Ich fühle mich mitschuldig,
auch wenn ich mich dagegen einsetze
und dabei
meine eigene Sicherheit riskiere."
"Bitte denkt daran, dass wir selbst
Geiseln von Banditen sind."
Zalina, wie geht es Ihnen?
Das Kriegsrecht
wird vielleicht eingeführt.
Was heisst das für Sie?
Mein Leben ist bedroht.
Wird das Kriegsrecht eingeführt,
können sie einen irgendwo
auf einem Platz erschiessen.
Was das für mich heisst?
Es ist nicht mehr lustig.
Ich brauche jetzt Hilfe
und kein Interview.
Verstehen Sie nicht, wo wir leben?
Wir leben praktisch in Nordkorea.
Nur ist es bei uns noch kälter.
Sie wollen alle,
die gegen den Krieg auftreten,
als Staatsverräter erklären
und drohen mit 20 Jahren Gefängnis.
Verrückt!
Ich habe gesehen,
dass Sie mutig weiterschreiben.
Ja, ich schreibe weiter.
Menschen sterben, da ist es
meine Pflicht, zu schreiben.
Und ja,
ich gefährde mich selbst damit -
aber das tun alle,
die dagegen auftreten.
Was sagt Ihr Mann?
Dasselbe. Er ist schockiert wie ich,
wie wir alle.
Wir wussten, es ist schlimm,
aber nicht, dass es so schlimm ist.
Entschuldigen Sie,
dass ich so emotional bin,
aber ich weiss nicht,
wie ich weiterleben soll.
Ich habe ein Kind
und kann nicht ausreisen.
Und es gibt keine Flugtickets
bis zum 7. März -
und heute ist der 3. März.
Eine Woche später reist Zalina -
vorerst allein - nach Armenien aus.
Es ist der 8. März, Frauentag -
ein Feiertag in Russland.
Auch dieses Jahr kaufen die Männer
ihren Frauen Blumen.
Demonstrationen für die Anliegen
der Frauen gibt es keine,
dafür steht auf Moskaus Plätzen
die Polizei
und schaut den Menschen
in die Taschen.
Wir haben bis zum Schluss
nicht glauben wollen,
dass unser Land
zu solchen Handlungen fähig ist.
Wir fühlen uns alle sehr schlecht.
In den ersten Tagen sassen wir
nur geschockt in unseren Büros
und fragten uns:
"Was können wir jetzt noch tun?"
Warum wollen nicht mehr Menschen
dagegen kämpfen?
Für alle, die nicht einverstanden
sind, gibt es einen Schlagstock.
Sie werden übrigens
aus Frankreich geliefert,
und dafür bedanken wir uns.
Wenn wir Ihre Antworten zeigen,
meinen Sie nicht,
dass das für Sie
gefährlich werden könnte?
Ich versuche, Worte zu wählen,
die nicht den Schmerzpunkt
von denen treffen,
die unser Gespräch anhören werden.
Aber heute
ist niemand mehr in Sicherheit.
Für jedes Wort kann man heute
hinter Gittern landen.
Der neueste Witz
unter uns Juristinnen ist:
"Werde ich
für diese Aussage verhaftet?"
"Warte,
ich schaue in den Tarotkarten."
Jetzt laufen schon die ersten
Strafverfahren wegen Fake News -
mit beantragten Strafen
von zehn Jahren Gefängnis.
Und es gibt
keine Möglichkeiten mehr,
mit irgendwelchen Aktionen
gegen die sog. Sonderoperation
aufzutreten.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Jubel *
Zehn Tage später
wird im Luschniki-Stadion
der achte Jahrestag
der Krim-Annexion gefeiert.
Über 100'000 Mitglieder aus
Jugendorganisationen sind aufgeboten.
Mir kommen die Worte aus
der Heiligen Schrift in den Sinn:
"Es gibt keine grössere Liebe ...
... als wenn jemand
für seine Freunde sein Leben lässt."
* Jubel *
* Dynamische Musik *
# Rossiya, Rossiya.
# V etom slove ogon' i sila.
# V etom slove pobedy plamya.
# Podnimaem Rossii znamya.
"Alle sind jetzt
auf sich allein gestellt."
"Die Leute 'reinigen' ihre Telefone
aus Angst vor Verhör und Folter."
"Und ich habe
bereits 400 Abonnent:innen weniger."
"Es ist beschämend,
sich zu beklagen,
wenn in der Ukraine
Menschen sterben."
"Und schmerzhaft, wenn meine
Verwandten dem Fernsehen glauben
und mir nicht."
Es ist Anfang April.
Zalina lebt noch immer in Armenien,
in der Hauptstadt Jerewan.
Jegor ist mittlerweile
mit Wanja nachgereist.
In Russland über Russland
zu schreiben, das geht nicht mehr.
Aber das Wort "Krieg"
brauchen auch Sie nicht?
Ich sage klar meine Meinung.
Aber ja, ich schreibe auch
"Spezialoperation".
Alles klar, mit Vorsicht.
Ja, ich bin etwas vorsichtig,
aber ich glaube nicht,
dass das hilft.
Das ist wie russisches Roulette.
Wenn sie wollen,
dann finden sie immer etwas.
Ja, genau.
Du kannst so vorsichtig sein,
wie du willst.
Sie wirken auf mich
recht gelöst und munter.
Ich habe das alles
halt auch schon mehrmals erlebt.
Unser Krieg hat bereits
vor zehn Jahren begonnen.
Und die Stimmung zu Hause?
Auch punkto Sanktionen?
Die Stimmung ist sehr schlecht.
Die Feindseligkeit
hat enorm zugenommen.
Russland ist ein gespaltenes Land.
Es gibt die Spaltung zwischen
den Vatniki, den Steppjacken,
und den anderen,
den frei denkenden Menschen.
Die Eltern meines Mannes
sind solche Vatniki.
Sie finden,
ich sei ein Feind des Volkes.
Ihr Kopf ist von der Propaganda
durchgewaschen.
Es ist unmöglich.
Und meine Mutter
weiss immer noch nicht,
dass ich abgereist bin,
aber ich will nicht
mit ihr sprechen.
Sie haben alle keine eigene Meinung.
Sie wiederholen,
was sie im Fernsehen
auf dem ersten Kanal hören.
Ihnen etwas beweisen zu wollen,
ist sinnlos.
Haben Sie noch Hoffnung?
Nein. Meine einzige Hoffnung ist,
weiter für mein Publikum
schreiben zu können,
das ist alles.
Für mein Land weiss ich nicht mehr,
worauf ich hoffen soll.
Ich mache in Moskau
eine Strassenumfrage.
Es wagen sich nicht mehr viele,
öffentlich zu sprechen -
ausser diejenigen, die die
Kreml-Propaganda übernommen haben.
Unser Präsident macht alles richtig.
Wir haben es satt
mit dieser Ukraine,
mit ihren Terrorattentaten.
Sie folterten unschuldige Menschen.
Die Ukraine
bombardiert unsere Mitbrüder,
gibt ihnen keine Möglichkeit,
normal zu leben.
Vor Kurzem haben sie
unser Territorium bombardiert,
Rostower Gebiet.
Warum müssen wir uns das anschauen?
Wir verteidigen uns.
Ich unterstütze Putin.
Wir haben den besten Präsidenten.
Aber Putin ist für den Krieg.
Er ist nicht für den Krieg,
im Gegenteil.
Ihr habt verschiedene Meinungen?
- (Beide) Ja.
Sie sagen,
dass Proteste nötig wären.
Und warum sind Sie nicht gegangen?
Gestern zum Beispiel?
Weil die Menschen verhaftet werden.
Und ich möchte nicht in
einem Gefangenentransporter landen.
Das fände ich nicht so angenehm.
Statt den friedlichen Menschen
zuzuhören,
transportiert man sie ab
und sperrt sie ein.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir sind zurück in Rostow.
Es ist Mitte Juni.
Der internationale Markt
ist für russische Models
kaum mehr zugänglich.
Ksenia arbeitet jetzt
auf dem lokalen Markt.
In drei Tagen hat sie Geburtstag.
Sie hat ein grosses Fest geplant.
Ich habe mir superknallige Nägel
machen lassen.
Und es kommen noch Wimpern dazu -
maximales Programm.
Ihr Sohn Ilja studiert mittlerweile
an einem Öl- und Gas-Institut
und arbeitet nebenher auf dem Bau.
Einige seiner besten Kollegen
hatten sich im Februar,
nach Ende des Grundwehrdienstes,
für zwei weitere Jahre verpflichtet.
Er wollte nicht.
Sein Mädchen hat auf ihn gewartet.
Er meinte,
er könne der Welt so mehr nützen.
Deshalb hat er nicht unterschrieben.
Du hast gesagt,
dass ein paar seiner Kollegen ...
... mittlerweile tot sind, ja.
Die, die unterschrieben haben.
Er war bei den Fallschirmjägern,
oder?
Ja, ich glaube.
Ich will jetzt
aber nichts behaupten.
Ich weiss nur,
dass er in Pskow stationiert war.
* Ksenia niest. *
Ich sage die Wahrheit.
Also ist er
um Haaresbreite davongekommen.
Ja, ist er.
Hat ihn der Tod der Freunde
mitgenommen?
Ja, sehr.
Er hat sogar geweint.
Und wie ist die Stimmung
jetzt in der Stadt?
Die erste Stresswelle
ist bei allen vorbei.
Alle passen sich an.
Aber Krieg ist immer irgendwo.
Die ganze Welt führt Krieg.
Darum wollen wir ja
eigentlich alle Frieden.
* Ksenia spricht russisch. *
Packen für die Geburtstagsfeier
am Schwarzen Meer.
Zwölf Freundinnen
haben ihr Kommen zugesagt.
Alles soll rot in Rot sein:
Die Kleider, die Dekoration -
einfach alles.
Ich möchte allen zeigen,
dass das Leben weitergeht.
Solange wir leben,
müssen wir uns des Lebens erfreuen.
Ich werde nicht unnötig
Trübsal blasen.
Ich spreche allen mein Beileid
und mein Mitgefühl aus,
aber wir leben weiter.
* Lockere Musik *
Eine Woche später
schickt mir Ksenia Fotos
von der Poolparty bei Sotschi.
Und ein paar Hundert Kilometer
weiter östlich, in Tiflis,
leben seit April Zalina und Jegor.
Sie haben Russland
definitiv verlassen.
Über 40'000 Russinnen und Russen sind
allein in den ersten Kriegswochen
in die georgische Hauptstadt
geflohen.
Zalina, Wanja und Jegor
leben in einer gemieteten Wohnung.
Häschen, brauchst du noch lange?
Und wie vorher in Moskau
schmeisst Jegor den Haushalt,
während Zalina Fernarbeit macht
und in ihrem Blog schreibt.
"Einige Männer beschweren sich
darüber, dass Feministinnen
in so schweren Zeit wieder nur
den Feminismus zum Thema machen."
"Aber warum waren fast alle,
die gestern in Bratejevo
inhaftiert wurden, Frauen?"
"Warum hat der Protest
wieder ein weibliches Gesicht?"
Bei Zalina ist die Konsequenz für
ihr Tun nicht Gefängnis, aber Exil.
"Ich kann keine Beiträge löschen."
"Das empfinde ich
als Beihilfe zu Mord."
Diejenigen, die geblieben sind,
die mussten löschen.
Aber das ist doch furchtbar.
Die Vernichtung der Persönlichkeit.
Man verbietet dir praktisch
zu existieren.
Es ist Ende Juli.
An der georgischen Küste
hat die russische Diaspora
ein Camp organisiert.
Zalina hält einen Vortrag.
Die Konservativen
haben die Begriffe der Familienwerte
und des Familienglücks
für sich monopolisiert.
Eine Feministin bedeutet Einsamkeit,
Schmerz, Leid und Unglück ...
... unrasierte Achseln
und unrasierter Arsch,
der piekst
und schlechte Laune macht.
Und die Frau im Patriarchat
ist eine flatternde Nymphe.
Alles ist toll,
obwohl zu Hause alles abgefuckt ist.
Das Problem in patriarchalen
Beziehungen besteht darin,
dass es hierarchische,
keine partnerschaftlichen
Beziehungen sind.
Familienglück ist gar nicht möglich
ohne feministische Werte.
* Applaus *
Spasibo.
Hier in Tiflis ist es gut.
Ich muss nicht mehr damit rechnen,
dass man mich mit dem Gesicht
auf den Boden drückt oder mich
für 15 Jahre einbuchtet, für nichts.
Haben Sie keine Angst,
dass Sie vielleicht
nie mehr zurückkehren können
und Ihre Heimat nie mehr sehen?
Manchmal habe ich Panikattacken.
Ich ersticke fast.
Kürzlich habe ich zwei Tage lang
geweint, wegen der Angst,
dass ich nicht mehr zurückkann.
Ich weine häufig deswegen.
Ich liebe Russland.
Ich wollte nie fort.
Dank der Arbeit auf Distanz
hätte ich schon früher gehen können,
habe es aber nicht getan.
Russland ist ein tolles Land.
Es gefiel mir sehr, dort zu leben.
* Beschwingte Marschmusik *
Mitte August:
Der Kreml zeigt in Moskau
an einer Messe Waffensysteme,
die auch in der Ukraine
eingesetzt werden.
Und Militärs verbündeter Nationen
erweisen dem Gastgeber ihre Referenz.
Wir schätzen es sehr,
dass unser Land
so viele Partner und Gleichgesinnte
hat, auf allen Kontinenten -
Staaten, die sich der sog.
Weltvorherrschaft nicht unterwerfen.
Ihre Führer zeigen
einen echten männlichen Charakter
und beugen sich nicht.
In der Innenstadt deutet nichts auf
den Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine hin,
auf Tot, Flucht, Verwüstung -
in einem Bruder-Land,
in dem viele Verwandte haben.
Und Mari Davtyan
arbeitet weiterhin als Anwältin
in Fällen von häuslicher Gewalt.
Auch wenn ein repressives Gesetz
nach dem andern eingeführt wird -
sie will ihren Posten halten,
solange es geht.
Die Menschen flanieren.
Es scheint, das Leben ist wie zuvor.
Nein. Die Anspannung
in der Gesellschaft ist enorm.
Aber die grosse Masse versteht,
dass sie nichts beeinflussen kann
und tut so, als wäre nichts.
Aber die Luft ist so dick,
dass man sie schneiden kann.
Wie zeigt sich das?
Man meidet es,
über gewisse Themen zu sprechen.
Man bricht das Gespräch ab.
Man vertraut einander nicht mehr.
Es wird wieder denunziert.
Die Leute zeigen einander an.
Es ist gerade eine schwere Zeit.
Was läuft in Ihrem Bereich
jetzt anders?
Jetzt wollen die Ultrarechten
aus dem Familienrecht
das Verbot der Gewaltanwendung
an Kindern herausnehmen.
Das beunruhigt mich sehr.
Sie sagen, ohne Prügelstrafe
seien ihre Elternrechte beschnitten
und pochen auf dieses "Recht".
Auf Gewalt?
- Auf das Recht auf Gewalt.
Im Moment führt alles weg
von der Rechtsstaatlichkeit.
Es gab mal eine Hoffnung
auf den Schutz der freien Meinung.
Davon träumen wir nur noch.
Demonstrationen für Frauenrechte?
Demonstrationen
gegen die Frauengewalt?
Vergessen Sie das!
Wer heute auf die Strasse geht,
wird aufgegriffen.
Zuerst waren es
alle politischen Organisationen.
Alle, die sich mit politischer
Beteiligung, Versammlungsfreiheit
und Redefreiheit befassten.
Die wurden als Erstes eliminiert.
Dann kamen die Medien.
Ein Bereich nach dem anderen.
Dann die Frauenorganisationen.
Warum machen die Frauen
nicht den Unterschied?
Die Idee,
dass Frauen auch eine politische,
wirtschaftliche und soziale Kraft
sein können,
die ist selbst den Frauen
noch nicht ganz klar.
Meine Hoffnung
liegt auf einer jungen Generation,
die sich dessen bewusst ist.
Wir sehen z.B.
die grosse Gruppe junger Leute,
die aufgrund des Fake-News-Gesetzes
verhaftet worden sind.
Da sind viele Frauen dabei,
fast mehr als die Hälfte -
junge Frauen,
die zehn Jahre jünger sind als ich.
Sie fühlen bereits ihre Kraft.
Und vielleicht
kommt irgendwann die Zeit,
in der diese Kraft mithilft,
dass sich Russland wieder
in eine andere Richtung bewegt.
* Ruhige Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022